without the discerning eyes of expert
editors every movie would probably be
four hours long and significantly less
awesome editors provide the pulse and
pacing tirelessly honing the creative
rhythm of films thanks to the skill and
artistry of these talented men and women
from vast shapeless pools of raw
material emerged beautifully crafted
films here are the nominees for
achievement in film editing American
hustle
Jake Asti Crispin Strether's and I'm Tom
Harkin
captain Phillips Christopher wells
Dallas buyers club John Mac McMurphy in
Martin concep gravity alfonso cuarón and
mark Schneider 12 years a slave Joe
Walker and the Oscar goes to for gravity
alfonso cuarón
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much a great honor I'd
like to thank our amazing team headed by
Tanner goading debs Richardson Steve
pang Steve mates Alistar Grimshaw Alex
fen and Ruth Antoine I I'd like to thank
my lovely wife mrs. Sanger over there
and all I can say is oh and there's a
and also the unsung hero in all of this
our executive producer Nikki penny there
is no greater accolade than to be
recognized by those who inspire you and
by that I mean you sir
my fellow nominees and the Academy thank
you very much indeed
[Applause]